destiny the taken king it's out we
talked about it a bit last week but we
couldn't talk about all of us because
the raid haven't been unlocked but it
has now right Mike my Hardy yeah you
played it yeah that was your weekend a
lot of destiny yeah it was good though
the rate especially is really a
highlight of the expansion stuffing
longest the boss at the end who will out
people might know who it is but I don't
know if that would be a spoiler to say
it don't say it then I won't um it's the
guy breaking bad yeah oh I'm Mike yeah
yeah I'm just kidding keep going it's
not like but ya know the raids really
great they're these you know that
interspersed mini bosses and I say many
I use that term flexibly because they're
pretty thing one has something like 16
million health or something Wow which is
just as much as it sounds but is it as
is it as difficult as when like you
played other raids in destiny first time
yes is that it's I'd say more so there's
a lot of first-person platforming which
I didn't like which I guess if you pull
out your heavy sword it wouldn't be
first person so I have to try that that
works um but anyway it's I don't know it
starts really it start school you're in
near the court of Oryx four people have
been playing it they know it's like that
public area where you're fighting boss
waves which is one of the highlights two
expansions as well but this I think is
air tastes footage I really hope we see
him fall off cuz he fell off but at the
time he was making fun of me for
something I just done and then he fell
off nizza listening right now there's a
lot of platforming stuff I saw Andy
playing a part where the the the the
like floors like appear in front of you
mhm as you like trying to get around
yeah you use your ghost and then it
highlights it's kind of like that leap
of faith and Indian Last Crusade instead
of salt you have yeah a couple of a
carpenter mm-hmm great destination and
so you've played the raid obviously we
talked last week sort of before the
review yet so you've reviewed taken King
now wats scored to get 8 8 out of 10 yep
tell us what's good about I got a bunch
of questions here from gamespot viewers
but first of all what is your take on
the taken King sure so I liked it a lot
as someone who played a lot of Destiny
year one or destiny vanilla you might
say with the two expansions house of
wolves and dark below I played a lot of
it but I wasn't always having fun
because a lot of the late game stuff is
repetitive and the story itself didn't
have much weight didn't lend much
context to what I was doing which I
learned a lot of credence to then a lot
of games I think if they can kind of
create this narrative and structure it
the campaign in a way that I feel
momentum carrying me forward I think
that lends a lot to the the missions
themselves and also you know a lot of
the bosses were bullet sponges and all
you were doing shooting going back in to
cover reloading pulling out your rocket
launcher shooting going back reloading
yeah never got that's why I find so much
of the action so TVs yeah I felt like I
was even same thing felt empty kya it it
was really promising to see these
gorgeous world before the game came out
and everything you're like oh we go to
Mars after it's been settled for a while
go to earth after its been destroyed by
this ball that not the trade the
traveler comes now the darkness follows
it and destroys earth and everything the
solar system in general and it'll be
cool to do all that but the world's
weren't as fun to explore as I was
hoping but with taken King the
dread-nots it's a ship in the rings of
Saturn that an intro cutscene shows it
you know coming up against the awoken
mmm fighting it that's the race of kind
of alien-human hybrid and it's like more
interesting area more stuff to do like
in what way is a more entertaining there
are more things to just find if you're
exploring there's a lot of chess there
these um chesty says you need these
specific keys again you don't know how
to do it this is the court of Oryx I
just mentioned before it's probably one
of them more fun things to do in the
expansion you put in these runes and we
head up to seven people at once like
fighting these bosses and there's tier 1
tier 2 tier 3 obviously higher tier the
harder they are here's another part of
this just coming so yeah there's a bit
of salt on Last Crusade kind of stuff
but yeah it's just overall it's a more
it's a little it feels I think it's like
on par with the size of Earth and
everything this is an actual earth yeah
it seems like this sort of Destiny they
should have launched with where it's
more fleshed out there's more cartoons
it's more like sort of rounded instead
of it being like a bunch of for me it
seemed like a bunch of like templated
combat instances there were sort of
ramshackle together in various different
ways a lot of repetition and stuff like
yeah whereas from your review add it
seems like there's a lot more variety a
lot more like depth each sure yeah
there's eight strikes if you're playing
on PlayStation there's one extra but the
bosses themselves are awesome in my
opinion I think
that contrary to what I was saying
before they still take a lot of damage
but in between that you're doing more
one of my favorites was called the
restorative mind and it's this vex enemy
and your he's invulnerable for a while
right here you can see it and then you
essentially have to coordinate with your
teammates to get this relic and then
bring it over to another kind of entry
point so he will lower shields and go to
fix it oh go on you start blowing up but
you also got this force field it's kind
of the arena it sounds like a donut
shape so he's rotating this forcefield
kind of dictating where you go so you
could think you're behind cover the
whole sudden you just feel something
pushing you to where you're shooting it
sucks but at the same time you're like I
could have avoided that if I thought
ahead and then you spawning these
enemies the whole time and the entire
time you're kind of just yelling back
and forth to each other like oh I'll
cloak you you go grab it and then you
distract him run over here that's cool
my combat variety within the boss but
instead of just picking a spot each
person to pop from behind cover Young
and then go reload then filling up
sponge full of bullets I got a bunch of
questions from folks I'm gonna get
through them pretty quick and Nick
Buster asks as a player fresh off the
boat does the old content from vanilla
destiny and the first two DLCs become
redundant yeah so as the expansion as an
expansion on its own taken Kings great
transformed a lot of what I didn't like
about destiny but you will if you're
starting from level one say and you're
going up to get the taken King you do
have a spark of light it's this item you
get from the postmaster that you can
just use pop and you will instantly be
double 25 ready for the king and with a
little bit better gear to be prepared
for that so I did that with one of my
carriage to see how it went and it was
that was fine but playing from level one
just I was curious how the quest log
would fit into it now that they redid
all the user interface stuff hmm you do
still have to go through that old stuff
I mean there's a better organization the
quest log the is the XP faster perhaps
like is the love of progression foster
mom it's no still the same speed but
once you hit 20 it doesn't stop I see
you right or 40 now which that was
refreshing because you know you get to
probably like Venus which is pretty
later on in the story and you might not
hit 20 by the end of the story I think
you could but you it won't be as
repetitive once you hit that so it's
it's still it's definitely worth getting
back into destiny I think if you were
either hesitating or if you kind of were
put off by it for a while which I was as
well so it's a good time to get back
into it because it not only has
mark on end game content to supplement
you know the grind later on which it
doesn't become a ground until like 15
hours in the takin care yeah but it does
help a little bit with the earlier game
stuff which I didn't love cool bit of a
slog though if you're starting off like
directly from the star chair okay cool
martin shepard asks feeling on the
elimination of the players base sorry
the playerbase that didn't buy all the
dlc they can't do a lot of things that
could do before so this was a big reddit
thread remember last week there's a
bunch of content that they were like
folks who haven't bought the taken King
had access to which they're kind of
being frozen out of and now what do you
think of all that aspect of it yeah
because from what I understand so when
the house of wolves came out you were
there are these public events instances
where you hunt these these wolf captains
and that would be a big part of playing
into the quests of the house of wolves
and then that got wiped later that
pretty much just became obsolete because
the taken king was coming out right and
also a lot of strikes which are pretty
essential like a strike playlist the
longer you stay in it the better chance
at good gear you have so these strikes
themselves are taking king strikes
though so i'm not sure if Bungie we have
reached out to ask if they're going to
try to rectify that yeah I'm sure if you
don't buy the taken King because the
pricing model for is still confusing to
me you can get all them for 60 now if
you haven't bought any of them is that
true but tanking on its own is 40 yeah
they definitely like that if you now
want to buy everything it's not like
where were you yeah it's good so
everything they have subsidized it
heavily for new people yeah so I hope
that's not the case I hope they do
something to rectify that because then
that the case would be if you're trying
to do all these strikes for a better
gear which they're pretty essential then
you won't be able to unless you're
thinking so I'm hoping that they'll
introduce a way for the older players
because you could still do the specific
strikes from vanilla destiny but that
won't be the strike playlist so you
won't have as good a chance of better
gears I'll get that streak going so let
the strike strength by that strike
strike a strike streak great
contribution beater so I'm here we'll
get to you in a second oh and megan
maestra ass
this bboy actually how close to the MMO
floor plan should bungee adhere to will
expansions like this be enough for ten
years is it starting to feel like it's
straining a little bit or does it not
well like would you be happy getting a
taken king or two taking Kings every
year and spending forty bucks of them
all taken King seems like it was doing
more to revamp destiny has a platform
which you know that's what Bungie
originally set out to do in addition to
make a game they just wanted to do
something that they could update yeah
throughout the years with paid DLC yeah
ten years seems like it would be a
stretch i know that's is that like
something they've well that destiny to
is probably they're gonna come out where
I think it will be a straight after a
while I think taken king is promising
because it's not it seems fresh to me
it's the first expansion I really liked
I play dark below and house of wolves
just out of obligation because not out
of obligation I wanted to play them
because you can get better stuff and it
was just I was interested to see how
destiny was morphing between expansions
yes but taken King was definitely most
drastic I don't think they're gonna do
something as drastic with each one maybe
there will be a destiny three point oh
that they'll you know kind of shape
depending on feedback from year to you
now that the patch is out and taking
king I don't see it being substantial
enough to last ten years but let me ask
the next question then a coffee Jesus
screen name asks where do you think
destiny goes from here more planets and
raids or another curveball entirely like
as a destiny van like looking towards
like they have this deal with Activision
that's going to go for at least another
eight years of them creating this
franchise whether they have like a new
boxed game where it all hits reset again
or whether they keep adding new packs to
destiny what is it do you want destiny
to be in like a year 18 months two years
oh yeah like I don't see them doing
another major update for at least
another year I know like the best part
about tanking was all based on feedback
so i think we'd have to wait and see
from my perspective I would very much
yeah like them to keep it be great to
keep going back to explore planets it's
just a bummer you have to pay every
single time you want to see that but I
mean the game is substantial on its own
now I know mercury is in the pvp maps
and we all kind of have suspicions that
might be the next thing they are gone
mercury is rising yep can you see
yourself playing this game in six months
if there is another piece of DLC because
the what
thing and it's if there isn't because
they would there will obviously but like
the one like massive criticism half of
this game is that I think it's been
completely purposefully designed so that
you have to keep your eye DLC because
the amount of content that's there just
isn't good enough it's not entertaining
enough and like people are getting bored
sort of like all we have to make in our
PC DIC and people will pay for it
because they've invested all this time
so like if they hadn't released another
forty dollar DLC let's say been like
april of next year would you keep
playing destiny now is that again that's
based entirely on these massive updates
that they're charging for yeah I think
so very much the thing separating like
just not to put too much weight on the
score but like I debated like what's
scored a given the thing that kept it
from being higher than an eighth was
after about 15 16 hours once you get
into the grind it's which I don't mind
grinding if I feel like it's worth it
but like you said it was kind of boring
you were doing you were taking out these
the same Walker tanks even shooting at
since the first strike the right of
Destiny your it's nothing substantial
enough there's no it's not a foundation
for this there's a foundation for a
growth in terms of expansion but not for
just anything emergent that comes out of
it from enjoying it on its own if they
weren't to release expansion I can't see
myself playing at six months
consistently like I am now at
interesting Destiny the destiny we have
now is different it was obviously a year
ago we originally reviewed at six out of
ten like who knows in trouble and slime
and might they might add so much
incredible interesting content that it
does have that sort of super longevity
without having the supplemental packs at
last question on this Peter as somebody
who enjoys lots of games online shooters
first-person shooters what is your take
on destiny you you don't play it right
much at all I've started to play it
casually and to be clear I don't play a
lot of multiplayer shooters I like
first-person shooters and third-person
shooters if it's the right game with
right mix of teams in action whatever
anyway that said destiny reminds me a
lot of phantasy star online which is a
game that I loved that was very short on
content and it was all about the hunt
for loot and I see everyone around the
office playing and that is sort of the
primary driving force and and I and I
can appreciate that right because it's
that sort of like reward mentality that
makes you feel good and there's nothing
wrong with it so I'm playing a casualty
to sort of get into it before I
completely missed the boat and because
it reminds me of the game I used to love
and because Sega will not release
Phantasy Star Online 2 in North America
I'm forced to play destiny
but you know I think the art direction
is wonderful i do like the the shooting
like the action feels good and I you
know I sort of hit even or early on some
boredom with the original version so I'm
I'm going to go through the grind and
earn my levels and not use the delights
park but I'm looking forward to actually
getting into the taken King stuff
because everyone sounds really positive
yeah about it you know to an extent so
given all my other curiosities like yeah
I'm curious to see where the series go
it's cool I'm happy for the destinations
welded seem to have gotten the expansion
back they have earned and deserve after
so much time playing as well but yeah
let us know in the comments what you
think destiny to taking I've been
playing since day one if you pick up the
taken King what do you think about it
let us know in the comments below